Patterns in GoF have three other sections. One is sample code and this may be
the largest section, in which in a variety of languages including C++ and
Smalltalk examples of coded uses of the pattern are included.
As a side note, this particular book was written before Java become popular,
so there are no java examples. However there are other books which include java
solutions to similar pattern problems. Next section is known uses.
As I said the authors of GoF were master designers and they had themselves had
written [or were familiar with many important object-orientated systems. And
they indicate which system use which patterns in this section of, of
each pattern description. And finally, in the final section is related patterns.
That is, how the given pattern relates to other patterns. Turns out that
elegantly written applications often use multiple co-operating patterns.
This is sometimes called pattern density. This section of
the book lists other patterns which might be used together with this pattern.